Hillary Clinton jumped in a van and she  drove from New York to Iowa yeah and  yesterday she was in Ohio and she  stopped at a Chipotle for dinner and  here's a picture from the security  camera there she is buying her meal at  Chipotle  so supporters are saying her stop at  Chipotle proves she's a regular  down-to-earth person who's got the  common touch and that seems to be their  theme in fact Hillary was so eager to  prove she has the common touch she made  other stops on the way to Iowa we just  got the photos minutes ago just pretend  she stopped by she stopped by a water  park to show she's a regular she we she  fought for a sweater at the Dress Barn  just like a regular  back into it she's got a [ __ ] stamp I  thought that was crazy she went to a  barrio in Cleveland and attended a  cockfight and a lot of money and she  crowd served at Coachella and  [Applause]  you